at nytimes.com and click on books love
and hate in Jamestown tells the story of
the founding of Virginia author David
Price as this week's history on book TV
feature it's 45 minutes well I want to
thank you all for first of all reading
love and hate in Jamestown and second of
all taking time away from your studying
to come here and talk about the book and
talk about Jamestown I thought I might
start out by reading a little bit from
from the first chapter kind of setting
the stage for the whole adventure that
the Jamestown colonists go through in
the year 1606 on a Roman tennis court
the artist Caravaggio killed an opponent
after an argument over a foul call a
middle-aged mathematician named Galileo
Galilei who had not yet built his first
telescope published a book of
observations about the recent appearance
of a supernova in the sky Japan's first
shogun ieyasu tokugawa had recently
begun his rule the Dutch painter
Rembrandt was born in Oxford Cambridge
and Canterbury 47 scholars appointed by
the king were laboring over a new
translation of the Scriptures which
would come to be known as the King James
Bible a new play called Macbeth opened
in London and in late December in
London's River Thames three small ships
were anchored awaiting a voyage across
the Atlantic
those three ships the Susan constant the
Godspeed and the discovery went on to
change the course of history after a
series of fruitless attempts by the
English to create an outpost in North
America
the voyagers of 1606 finally broke
through the colony that they established
at Jamestown would open the way for
later English settlements up and down
the east coast and eventually for the
United States itself I'm curious
when you learned about Jamestown in your
US history class here when you read the
book was that pretty much how you
imagined the United States English
America had had gotten started way back
when or had you do you feel like you'd
been led to assume something different
about about America's roots I was
surprised when I started my research
that religion and Christianity wasn't
really so much at the center of it as
profit-making the Virginia company that
settled Jamestown having been you know a
corporation that was basically in it for
the money I mean did any of you all sort
of feel like you came to this whole
subject with some misconceptions like
that when you're first learning about in
an elementary school you're learning
about the colonies you they focus mainly
on New England and Massachusetts and the
Pilgrims and they talk about Jamestown
bit but they mostly focus on the
summit's there because I guess in
elementary school they're more of
settlements because those were families
and they had religious practices reasons
for their voyages rather than money you
know the pilgrims get all the publicity
for some reason I'm not sure why that is
anybody you know have any questions
occurred them when they were when they
were reading a settlement and on these
voyagers and and yet at the end of your
prologue you say that people were coming
to America thinking that it was gonna be
easy and I was just wondering why they
had those misconceptions if in fact
these previous voyagers and travelers
had
I think there was a lot of wishful
thinking quite honestly I mean the um
the English at that time had seen the
Spanish create an empire in South
America Central America parts of North
America and they had gotten just
incredible riches out of it I mean gold
was there for the taking they stole it
is what happened and I think the English
sort of looked at the success that the
Spanish had and I think you know at a
certain level that kind of wealth can
sort of make you forget you know some of
the hard realities and I can only assume
that's what happens to them when started
to cheese steam sound I don't call those
possible settlements that you could have
been focused in um I guess my
involvement with the started when the
when the Disney movie came out in the
mid nineties the pecans be I'm sure
we've all seen it and um and I had grown
up in Virginia and so I knew sort of
just enough about the real story to know
that the Disney version was just sort of
you know ridiculously fictionalized and
um and I've actually kind of softened on
the movie now now I think it's sort of
an okay movie as long as you understand
you know you know it is what it is but
when it came out I was I kind of thought
this would be kind of an easy thing to
make fun of and so I wrote an article
for The Wall Street Journal sort of
looking at the movie and then looking at
the sort of the real history and sort of
pointing out the differences and and I
really figured that that would kind of
be the end of my involvement in the
story I got I guess in just in
researching that short article I got
really interested in the characters and
sort of the adventures and everything
and so it was a hobby for a long time
after that and then finally I I guess
maybe four or five years ago I got the
idea of actually writing a book about it
and so that's how it all started
but there's the scene in the movie where
they're like you know this yellow stuff
and Pocahontas is like oh we have lots
of that it's corn and he wants gold
right I'm wondering when the book makes
it clear that the Virginia Company was a
for-profit venture but what were they
looking for in profits were looking for
for trade or did they expect to find
another Aztec another in Incan Empire in
the north well you really hit the nail
on the head they really thought that
they were going to come over and the
Indians essentially were going to lead
them where they were gonna find on their
own deposits of gold and silver and you
know life was just gonna be you know
wonderful and everyone was gonna you
know go home you know rich and so I mean
there's a lot about the movie that's
fictionalized but I mean through that
one you know angle I think is true and
they came over there hoping to find gold
and of course you know that was
completely unrealistic you mentioned
Peggy V song I'm wondering did you come
across why is it that we have this urge
to romanticize Pocahontas and Johnson
well I guess there's something sort of
innate I mean whenever you're telling a
story that sort of starts out with you
know a man save you know a woman or or
or or a woman saving a man which is what
happened here you sort of if you're you
know writing you know the story of
course the man and the woman have to end
up together in the end and it just just
doesn't work out at all if the man
leaves and the woman winds up with some
other guy so I think um there's been I
think sure like you know our
expectations you know listening to a
story I think are probably what got the
Disney people to sort you know rewrite
things not only the Disney people I mean
lots of people who've written plays and
novels about it over the years it's sort
of you know adjusted things to sort of
you know make it come out with a happy
ending like that
when you began your research how did how
did you start it did you find because I
would think that most of the documents
would have been lost by now was there
library that kept most of these
documents or because this was very
in-depth research I just don't know
where you would have spirit a lot of
documents have been lost but there's
actually more still around than you
would think
letters Chronicles books that were
published at the time the Virginia
company records a lot of those have been
preserved and so I had access to all
this stuff through the Library of
Congress rare book room other libraries
a lot of materials have been sort of
collected by scholars and so I mean
believe it or not even though it is 400
years ago you can get a hold of a lot of
material that gives sort of a
first-person perspective of what people
were going through
besides the world of Christianity play
for the colonies where they're knew
their surprises you have things that you
know
or you can see yeah I think I think for
me the major one was the idealism of the
English at that time the I think when
you sort of look at the whole course of
you know the last 400 years you
obviously see you know a lot of racism
on the part of of you know the English
settlers later on and then you know
later the Americans themselves but in in
those first years there was really this
idea that they would come over subtle
and that no one else was living on they
didn't mean to displace the natives the
Indians and then over time as the
natives were sort of exposed to the
English way of life they would kind of
embrace English ways and sort of
gradually become English people
themselves and obviously that was a very
naive you know set of expectations that
they had but I mean the fact that their
intentions were a lot better I think
than people sometimes give him credit
for at the very beginning was a real
surprise to me
like John White left his family here for
years and did he is it probable in any
communication during these three years
that's right no I mean I mean it's
obviously hard for us to picture but um
I mean really I mean the only form of
communication was you know if a ship
happened to be going or a ship happened
to be coming it would come carrying
letters or it would take letters away
and that was it there was a large
massacre in 1622 in March of 1622 and
the news of it took so long to go from
Virginia back to England that um a month
after this Massacre happened there was a
sermon to the Virginia Company where
this preacher was talking about how
wonderful you know the relationship was
between the natives and the colonists
and you know everyone's happy and we're
all you know you know brothers who love
each other and so people had no idea
what was going on until months after it
happened or or years in that case and
it's pretty interesting to me kind of
mysterious I just something what you
thought happened to it
yeah this you know I've thought about
that for a long time and I haven't
really come up with a good theory about
I mean you know you I'm sure knew the
story you know for a long time how they
were left there and then when the next
ship came back nothing was found no
people no sign of any struggle just just
a word on a post and um I mean one
theory that's out there is that they
actually ran off and joined the Indians
we decided to live like Indians because
they were having trouble surviving but
that's possible but in in later in
accounts of the Jamestown Colony they
were sort of very aware of the Lost
Colony and I think they were you know
very much on the lookout for any
information they could run across and if
that had happened I think it would have
become known I mean this sort of this
were like a settlement of Europeans
living in the woods it sort of would
have surfaced and been talked about so
so I don't know
settlement of Jamestown there was a lot
of hardship that the English went
through and I know they depended on the
natives a lot but do you think what
really sustained them through that
initial period was entirely the economic
benefit that they hope to acquire or do
you think there was an innate need that
they felt because they were civilized
people to kind of tame the land not just
the natives but the actual land the idea
of this mystery to kind of tame it and
have it as their own
well I mean that's an interesting idea
and probably for some people yes you
have to remember though that I mean the
majority the people who came over there
were not the sort of rugged hardy kind
of snow outdoorsy survivalist types I
mean they were pretty soft I guess is is
the reality and so there's probably
there could have been a minority of
people like that who sort of saw it as
the sort of this big adventure and we
have to tame the wilderness and
everything I think a major element and
why they stuck it out is that they
actually didn't have a choice once
they've gotten on the ship and the ship
had brought them over to Virginia they
didn't have a right to go back and and
in fact there were multiple efforts to
basically run off with one of the ships
that was left behind and try to sail
back to England and nobody ever made it
I mean they could actually be fired on
and it was considered a crime to try to
abandon it once you've made that
commitment so it's it was obviously a
terrible situation to find yourself in
but I think a lot of the sort of
tenacity was not by choice
in them he discusses how the English
want to impart their civilization with
the Indians that went through MIT's
attempt for them how did they go about
doing that and do they have any effect
on unions they didn't have they didn't
have much effect in the way they wanted
to the Indians really understood the
value of the the weapons and the metal
tools and they were very interested in
getting a hold of those and they would
trade their food for that but I think
the intention of sort of winning the
natives over to Christianity and to sort
of the notion of English Liberty and so
on you know they didn't make any real
headway with that and I think that's one
of the reasons why Pocahontas was a
really celebrated figure even at that
time is because she was sort of the one
native who did convert to Christianity
and then it was sort of sent back to not
that she was the only one to convert but
she was one of a very small number who
converted and as the Chiefs daughter
that sort of made her sort of a
celebrity but um no they they weren't
very effective in reaching out to the
natives and obviously I think you have
to assume that the natives were pretty
happy living the way they had been you
know living for so many centuries by and
large how these soft men or the
gentlemen that you were talking about
get the money and the ships more
importantly the crew to go over to go
over to America because they absolutely
would have needed a lot of people to run
the boats the ships if they won't do it
themselves the um well the Virginia
Company was financed at first by sort of
a small group of investors who put a lot
of money into it then a couple years
down the road there was actually a
public stock offering and so sort of
anyone could buy a share of the Virginia
Company so they had the capital to start
with so they were able to essentially
lease or buy the ships it depends on the
ship they hired the crew so
those people were working for money the
sailors would sail the ships over they'd
hang around for a little while but then
they'd go back so they weren't sort of
part of the part of the enterprise
really they were sort of hired
transportation basically what made an 11
year old girl go to help English people
and why did they listen to her if she
was just 11 years old hmm well I think
she every English person who wrote about
her at that time she spoke of her
personality has been very sort of
spirited and and sort of independent and
I guess it was just four than her nature
to be curious about this very sort of
alien group of people who'd settled
there and when John Smith was rescued by
Pocahontas
he spoke later in a letter to to the
Queen about her compassionate pitying
heart and so she was I think she was
curious about the English and then in
rescuing this one man I think she felt
you know compassion and I guess
curiosity for this for this man who was
about to be executed in front of her as
far as why her father listened to her
a chief pout and you have to imagine I
guess the scene where this took place it
was a large we think of wigwams the the
natives native dwellings has been
there's a very small huts and a lot of
them were small but where this assembly
took place was a very large one where
there were good hundred or so people
assembled and when Smith was about to be
executed at chief powtoons order it was
a very dignified occasion Chief Powhatan
himself everybody remembers him as being
this very sort of stately very formal
man and so when Pocahontas jumps into
the scene he sort of put on the spot and
I
I know I guess there's different
theories you can have but it seems to me
that he probably felt like that was sort
of the most graceful way out of it is to
sort of call the execution off and sort
of placate is his 11 year old daughter
you are talking about how the English
disapproved of the Spanish conquistadors
previous treatment of Indians in South
America and I was just wondering they
the English claim that their
relationship was pretty peaceful with
the Indians and I was wondering if that
actually it was the case and if there
weren't that many conflicts well the for
the first I would say seven eight years
of the colony there was sort of a cold
war going on between the the powtoons
and the English in Jamestown by that I
mean they weren't really fighting an
open war which is a good thing for the
English because I mean they probably
would have been wiped out if that had
happened instead they were sort of minor
conflicts here and there but they were
at the same time they were trading with
one another there's with I guess the
best way to think of it is they're sort
of like circling each other very war
elite and they're sort of trying to
assess one another's intentions I'm in
the very early years
chief pout and doesn't really know
whether they even plan to stay or not
they sort of they try to convey the idea
that they're just sort of there
temporarily you know their ships broke
down they needed to rest for a while so
there's a lot of confusion on both sides
about the intentions of the other side
and then when Pocahontas marries John
Rolfe in 1614 that begins a period of
peace that lasts for another seven years
sort of the early stages they're they're
sort of hostile to each other but it
doesn't really erupt into warfare and
that's a lot different from the Spanish
experience
the Native American viewpoint when
you're doing your research was it
through oral tradition because it
certainly wasn't books that were
published in it right let's mean I think
for anyone who's researching this part
of history that's probably like the
number one frustration is that there's
no first-person accounts sort of from
the Indians own words the natives didn't
have any written language at that time
and I don't think that you know an oral
tradition over a period of 400 years is
very reliable in any case I never found
in the world tradition to draw and for
the period I was looking at what we do
have is the English observations of the
natives stories that the natives told
the English that they wrote down in
their books and there's actually quite a
bit of that because the English back
home were very interested in the natives
and you know anything that they could
get ahold of in books that would sort of
talk about in the the Indian Way of life
was something that sold very well and
had a very big audience and so quite a
few of the colonists did take it upon
themselves to you know make notes of
what they saw and other observations of
native life and and obviously there's
you know some bias in that in other
words it's not a hundred percent
reliable but I mean ologists today even
if people who study these cultures feel
like there is a lot there that you can
rely on that they really were you know
making an effort to sort of get at the
truth and not just sort of you know
paint up sort of a one-sided picture
the settlers could have returned to
England what maintain them in Jamestown
was it maybe a sense of community or did
they learn how to adapt quickly like
like what what did they do in order to
survive well I mean the answer is there
wasn't really any way out I guess to
make a long story short I mean a number
of English people did sort of go and
live with the natives that worked for a
while that was an option but I mean by
and large they're sort of stuck there
and a lot of them died there sort of you
know one year after another where you
see you know 80% of the colonists you
know dying over the summer or over the
winter and one of John Smith's big
contributions was to sort of recognize
that as much as you know the English
were proud of their way of life you know
it it wasn't gonna get them through that
they really needed to learn from how the
natives did things and to imitate their
way for instance getting through the
winter so I mean there were but you know
time after time you sort of see the you
know the the college starting with maybe
five hundred people you know at the
beginning of the year in January and
then sort of by September
you know after there's been sort of a
bad summer with all the malaria and and
everything there they could be down to
you know 50 people or 100 people so it's
really appalling how many people died
and and it's amazing in retrospect that
you know the Virginia Company was
allowed to send so many people to what
you know was pretty much you know almost
certain death know year after year
survive if the original a company wasn't
able to continue sending people it was
just like another Lost Colony and it
just had it so if it hadn't survived and
flourished the way it had yeah well I
think that's a very important issue in
my opinion is that if if there had been
if Jamestown had become another Lost
Colony and all that sort of money had
been sunk into it and nothing came out
of it I'm not sure that we'd be that
America would be an english-speaking
country today and I think probably
instead of being dominated by the
English and English traditions I think
it would probably be probably Spanish
and Spanish tradition you know possibly
French they kind of had a toehold on but
probably Spanish from there sort of the
premier along with the Portuguese they
were really the premier colonizers at
that time and and it's almost I mean I
think it's almost a fluke that so much
of North America turned out to be
English no one would have ever guessed
that 400 years ago and I think you know
the possibility that you know after
Roanoke sort of you know fails Jamestown
fails the idea that you would have been
able to find you know more investors in
England to try it again I think it's
very unlikely
so how did they write well at first it
was through signs through gestures there
there was some knowledge of the
Algonquian language that was um brought
back by the Roanoke colonists it sort of
reduced to a phrase book but by and
large the early communications was
through gestures and like if you're in a
foreign country
and you don't know the language but then
gradually there were interpreters who
emerged on both sides people who've
learned you know English people who
learned the native language and vice
versa
John Smith was one of those who should
have made it his business to learn the
Algonquian language so that he could you
know deal effectively with them trade
with him negotiate Pocahontas was one
who learned as much as she could of the
English language but it was it was a
sort of a gradual process and it
obviously it's kind of hard to imagine
well how did they function you know how
do they deal with each other you know at
a point when you know the two cultures
are so completely alien but is sort of a
lot of sort of trial and error on both
sides
that's right that's right that's right
Fred she has this magical ability to
yeah those a little bit a little bit
different
many of the common English people
actually knew about Jamestown and
settlement and if they did what were
their thoughts on it how did they react
to them settlement at at the level of
the commoners we don't really know that
much about it and we know that if you
sort of go a few rungs up the social
ladder in England the sort of the gentry
was very interested in I mean there's a
lot of them when it became sort of a
public company so to speak a lot of them
did invest in it and took a great
interest in it in truth hopes to get
rich from it but but we don't really
know you know what sort of the man on
the street thought about it well I mean
there's you know there's all these you
know claims about who had the first
Thanksgiving and and obviously the one
that we celebrate him in is the pilgrim
Thanksgiving and there were then you
know people from Virginia do argue that
there was a Thanksgiving before that at
Berkeley plantation and you know it
could be true I didn't I didn't research
that I have to admit but then I mean
there's another Thanksgiving to me
that's kind of interesting that comes
after the Pilgrims Thanksgiving and
after the massacre in 1622 where a
quarter of the colony was killed in in
one day in a native attack and the the
government of the colony at that time
decrees that that day will be celebrated
as a Thanksgiving holiday because they
want to express their gratitude for as
many of them having survived as did
survive and they didn't they didn't sort
of focus on sort of the well they did
focus on the horror of the event but in
sort of defining this holiday they
didn't want it to be sort of the day of
sort of sorrow and
remembrance of you know of what happened
so much as Thanksgiving that you know
some of us did make it and that to me
was kind of an interesting perspective
that I hadn't that I hadn't expected and
I guess I guess we're sort of as far as
what who had the first Thanksgiving I
mean I think we're stuck with the
pilgrims thanks explorers were afraid
that there would be malaria they didn't
know that they're in a climate where
malaria cannot be sustained so they
brought trees to make medicine and
completely change the entire environment
but like what kind of things were they
afraid of and how many of those fears
were actually here's what was completely
unexpected well at this stage people are
much less sophisticated about about
things like that and sort of their early
1600s but um they were concerned that
the natives that they encountered would
be cannibals not just in North America
but um
their route took them actually south and
then across to the Caribbean and they
stopped on a number of Caribbean islands
to get new supplies and and whatnot
before they continued up the coast to
Virginia and so they were very concerned
that the natives there as well as in
Virginia would be eaters of human flesh
and that wasn't true
actually some of the ones in the
Caribbean at that time were but the ones
in Virginia were and they were very
afraid of Spanish attack and that was
probably their number one fear that the
number one fear of the Virginia Kyle
company at home and the fear of the
colonists in Jamestown was that there
one morning that they wake up and a
fleet of Spanish warships would have you
know come up come into the Chesapeake
Bay up the James River and just take
care of him meaning wipe them out and
that never happened for different
reasons but that's really what they were
prepared for and that's what there
for hence for them what made the
settlers what made the company really
pick Virginia the area of genera where
if they were going through the Caribbean
it would have been either easier for
them to say go to North Carolina South
Carolina area now or or go further up
the Chesapeake or something like that
what we then picked that particular area
well the UM
as far as why they chose the Chesapeake
Bay and then why they settled where they
did on the James River they they wanted
to get a stay as far away as possible
from from the Caribbean from the West
Indies because that was Spanish
dominated they sort of you'd have made
this little short pass through it on
their way but they had a very realistic
idea that if they tried if they settled
there or if they settled like in the
Florida area or something like that
they'd be very exposed to the Spanish
attack that they were so afraid of and
that's also probably the main reason why
they located where they did on the James
River they wanted you know not to be too
far up River
because they were afraid that um if they
were it was far enough inland then there
would be native tribes sort of closer to
the coastline that was making alliance
with the Spanish and sort of guide the
Spanish to them and help the Spanish
make war on them so so much of their
decisions in the earlier were really
driven by this sort of paranoia about
about Spanish attack
Kaymer ownerships for the sort of
gallant gentleman who were used to such
luxuries and Samantha's not terribly
happy with them what made them if they
were so accustomed to life's luxuries
want to take you know a six-week voyage
across the sea to an unknown land
um I think a lot of them didn't really
appreciate what they were in for I mean
I think they had an ocean in fact it's
very clear they had an ocean that much
more was gonna be done for them that
they weren't gonna have to do any work I
know the sort of the company was somehow
going to make food appear for them and
you know the the ocean voyage was you
know incredibly hard no one actually
died on the on the voyage across but it
was very it's very tough to live on
those crowded ships but no one had ever
none of these people had ever done it
before they didn't really know what they
were getting themselves into I think you
know they're you know very optimistic
about getting rich quick and didn't
really understand that would mean you
know living in these really smelly you
know below decks holds of a tiny little
ship for months at a time
gentlemen coming if they had some talk
today right and like a sign-up sheet her
this money here right well I mean a lot
of the people who were on the ships did
have connections especially family
connections to to major investors in the
company so clearly that was very
important if you sort of had an in with
the Virginia Company he sort of moved to
the head of the line as far as being
able to be one of the hundred and five
or so people on that first expedition
and I mean I think for me the real
question or the real mystery is well how
did someone like John Smith who is a
commoner wind up on board and and that's
something that we've never really saw of
him there's you know some you know
possible connections that he had but he
was sort of very uncharacteristic of the
people who were chosen for leadership
roles most of them came from this upper
crust that had put money into the
Virginia Company the barriers between
the gentlemen
lower ron shipp once they've got to the
territory realized what they really
needed to do and his policy of if you
want the benefits of our work then you
have to be included in the work where
those barriers actually broken down in
any way yeah but it took a while to get
to that point he was part of the ruling
council of the colony from the beginning
and he's sort of in charge of relations
with the with the natives but he doesn't
actually become president for for a
couple of years in and so for this first
couple of years served the class
consciousness of england back home has
sort of really been brought over and
that causes a lot of the problems that
they have where they're sort of
perennial ii without enough food they
don't have you know shelter to keep them
you know out of the out of the winter
weather
so it's it's only when he takes over
that he's able to sort of stand up and
say he that shall not work will not eat
and so the barriers come down because he
knocks him down basically
that the word savage actually didn't
have the connotation we have today that
it meant like evil or whatever you just
said that to the Englishman at the time
that savage adjustment I'm Christian
that's right yeah when do you think that
the connotation of the word changed and
why do you think it did the the word
savage in the very early years of the
colony as you've mentioned to the
English didn't have the baggage that it
obviously has today and I far as when it
took on that connotation I think
probably I don't know to be honest with
you sir I'm sort of taking a guess here
but I bet I'm I think probably when the
natives and the English sort of had
their relations take a turn for the
worst in the 1620s and were basically at
war with each other
I would guess that's when you started to
see the word savage be this word a sort
of extreme derision and inferiority that
it hadn't been up to that time
we take to the name where today do they
think is acceptable or was it just a
great question that's the great question
which I don't know the answer to
um I think um I mean to the extent it
was used you know I don't need to know I
don't even know so I don't want to wing
it true that Americans claim direct
descendants II to John Ralph and is that
true is that kind of a thing no that's
that's true I mean a lot of the Virginia
aristocracy does have some lineage back
to John Rolfe and Pocahontas a son
Thomas Roth and actually that led to an
interesting exception to the laws that
Virginia enacted during the 19th century
against interracial marriage that the
racist laws of that time basically said
that you know whites couldn't marry
non-whites and vice versa but they had
to make an exception to that because so
many of the Virginia Gentry in fact had
native blood in them from Pocahontas so
they actually had to write in a
Pocahontas exception basically so that
these people could could get married
which obviously shows the ridiculousness
of there's loss in the first place but
yeah it is it is a fact that a lot of a
lot of a lot of folks do trace their
bloodlines back to Thomas role when the
colonists
in the New World and they were really
vulnerable and just sort of out in the
open and I was wondering what your
opinion was about why the Native
Americans didn't completely just sort of
way from that and I think um I think
that was probably chief Palin's biggest
mistake and he was the Emperor of a
region that was basically the eastern
half of Virginia and um he was a very
astute man and he had conquered a lot of
native tribes before that time and he I
think it's pretty clear
I'm just wasn't sure for the longest
time what to do with with the English
until it was basically too late I think
in in in the early years he saw that
they had these tools and weapons that
were something that he could use against
his enemies there were enemy tribes to
the west and to the north and so if he
could make allies of the English or use
their guns or get hold of their swords
he'd have a real advantage in dealing
with his other enemies and then then -
they probably English were probably not
taken very seriously by the natives in
those early years they remember they
couldn't feed themselves they were
constantly having to go to the
neighboring tribes to swim you know beg
for food to trade for food so chief pout
and probably I mean he there's nothing
that sort of tells us in his words but I
think if you look at the situation you
have to assume they probably just
figured that these people would die out
of their own accord they were helpless
without without someone feeding them
which is obviously a pretty poor
commentary on their on their abilities
I've been to do several times and it's
always interesting people in Victoria
question so what's the relationship
between Williamsburg and Jamestown I
just never really encouraged me do wings
burn come around a lot later yeah
Millie's bird becomes the colonial
capital you're quite a bit later like
like a century later something like that
in the book how John Smith pretty much
is able to have the settlement survive
without without all the blood that the
Spanish required of killing just the
Indians how exactly was he able to
negotiate between the two because I
don't know
besides the language marries but the I
don't know if the English really wanted
to deal with the natives and natives won
the deal with the English well he had
this really good understanding of human
nature and he was able to keep a chief
pout and know off balance for a long
time by basically exaggerating the
strengths of the English in terms of the
ability the capabilities with their
weapons
keeping chief mountain in the dark about
what the English colonies intentions
were and then sort of you know leaving
this ambiguity that maybe he'd be able
to help chief pout and and deal with
these other tribes that he was scared of
so there was a lot of a lot of
psychology really last I'm told we have
time for one more question
did she figure out the psychology that
was being used on her father and she was
kind of a middle woman between her two
cultures how do you think that affected
her as a young child and was relating to
as she mature she Pocahontas had real
divided loyalties I mean from probably
her first dealings with the English and
her father used her as a middle woman
like you said with the English but at
the same time I mean she saved John
Smith's life on more than one occasion
she's a leader to the English obviously
and she was I guess you have to say if
she's a little bit disloyal and and how
much of you know the English strategy
she understood when I mean we're not
really sure but she you know really
became part of that strategy to some
extent well this has been really
interesting I really appreciate you all
coming up with these great questions
it's fun David Price is the author of
love and hate in Jamestown it's
published by Knopf visit Random House
dot-com / Knopf for more information
next week on history on book TV citizen
hobo todd de pastino chronic